You're having a movie marathon.
Each movie lasts
about 1 and 3/4 hours.
If you want to watch
3 movies, how long
will your movie marathon last?
You can use the
number line below
to help you find your answer.
So each movie lasts
1 and 3/4 hours long.
So let's say the
first movie happens
to be Star Wars,
which I probably
would include in
any movie marathon.
So it's going to be
1 and 3/4 hours long.
So this is 1,.
1, and then we're
going to have 3/4 more.
So each of these are
a fourth because we
have 4 sections between
1 and 2-- 1, 2, 3, 4.
So we're going to watch 3/4.
1, 2, 3.
So that's how long
my first movie is.
And then, my second movie is
going to be another 1 and 3/4.
So 1 is 4/4.
So 1, 2, 3, 4.
And then we're going
to have another 3/4.
1, 2, 3.
And just as the way I said
that, 4/4 and 3/4 is 7/4.
So 1 and 3/4, that's
the same thing as 7/4.
And you see that over here.
When I did the 1
and 3/4 in blue,
I actually marked off 7/4.
Same thing here,
here in magenta.
And now, let's do it in green.
So Gandhi is actually a good
bit longer than 1 and 3/4,
but it's a good movie,
so I put it here
just because it's
one of my favorites.
And so let's do another
1 and 3/4 hours.
Or we could do that as 4/4
plus 3/4 hours, or 7/4.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
So that gets us to 5.
So this point right over
here is 5 and 1/4 hours.
Now, let's see if we
get that same result
when we do it mathematically.
I guess this is
mathematical as well.
But every movie lasts
1 and 3/4 hours.
We already said
that 1 and 3/4 is
the same thing as 1 plus 3/4.
1 is the same thing as 4/4.
So it's 4/4 plus 3/4, which
is the same thing as 7/4.
And another way to
convert this mixed number
into an improper fraction,
you say, hey, look.
4 times 1 is 4--
and that's really
where you're getting the
4/4 from-- plus 3 is 7.
7/4.
Now, we're going to do 7/4
of an hour three times.
So we're going to
multiply 7/4 times 3.
Now, there are several ways
that you could think about this.
You could literally view
this as having three 7/4
and adding them together.
So 7/4 plus 7/4 plus 7/4,
which would be equal to 21/4.
And if you wanted to convert
this into a mixed number,
21/4 is the same thing as--
well, 4 goes into 20 evenly.
So you could call
this 20/4 plus 1/4.
And 20/4 is the same thing as 5.
So it's 5 and 1/4, which is
exactly what we saw here.
Another way of thinking
about it, you could say 7/4.
And then we can multiply
it by 3/1, times 3/1,
just to make it clear that
we're multiplying the numerators
and multiplying
the denominators.
So in the numerator, I'm
to have 7 plus 7 plus 7.
That's 7 times 3.
And in the
denominator, I'm going
to have 4 times 1,
which is just 4.
Well, this is just
7 times 3 over 4,
or 21/4, which we've
already seen is 5 and 1/4.